[Music]
for those of us who eat sleep and
breathe all things Disney we'd love to
incorporate it into our everyday routine
so why not start with the place where we
begin and end our day we would all love
to sleep in some of these gorgeous
castles like our favorite princesses do
you want to transform your room into a
Disney Wonderland watch our video and
find out how if you're new to our
channel don't forget to click the
subscribe button and give our video a
big thumbs up get ready to get crafty
because today we are going to show you
10 most epic Disney themed bedrooms ever
Sleeping Beauty the good-natured fairies
flora fauna and Merryweather sure know
how to make us laugh they're sassy and
caring personalities made us want to
live in a cottage in the woods although
when it came to their domestic skills
they weren't the greatest unless they
used magic when they created a dress for
Princess Aurora it was originally pink
but of course the fairies disagreed the
eternal make it pink versus make a blue
dress debate still causes feuds among
fans but not to worry
because the designers of this bedroom
chose pink the pink and white colours
revamp the Victorian style furniture it
definitely says Princess Aurora
especially with that giant pink castle
framing the doorway to the bedroom
behind the headboard is a set of fabric
boards and some beautifully draped
curtains this definitely looks like it
could be in princess Aurora's bedroom in
the movie they even have her pink dress
ready when a story is about someone
sleeping it makes sense to use it as
inspiration for a bedroom we would love
to be the Sleeping Beauty who gets to
sleep in here let's just hope this room
doesn't include curses or fire-breathing
dragons Beauty and the Beast when you
have a tale as old as time why wouldn't
you draw inspiration from it Disney's
Beauty and the Beast is a wonderful
story of the everyday girl falling in
love with a prince but of course the
prince is a beast when these two
Outsiders change each other's lives true
love grows and appearances don't matter
isn't that sweet we love the story but
what we really love about this movie is
the interior design of the cast
Lumiere and all of the other pieces of
furniture that are alive might have
something to do with it after all who
wouldn't love talking to furniture but
since we can't have that we will work
with the next best thing
this bedroom took a page from the
ballroom scene in the movie the colorful
walls and faux stained-glass windows
make us feel like we are in the castle
the lovely ruffled bedspread is just
like Bell's iconic dress this other
bedroom is located in one of Tokyo's
Disneyland hotels it looks like this is
inspired by Belle's library we love that
the furniture totally looks like it
could come to life there are even roses
on the headboard and Lumiere and
Cogsworth in the bookshelf all we need
is a ton of books Toy Story Playhouse as
kids we always wanted our toys to come
to life and be able to reenact the
stories we imagined in our heads Disney
and Pixar's hit Toy Story lets us live
out our dreams with The Adventures of
Woody Buzz and all of the other toy
friends Andy's room was always something
we wanted from the cloud wallpaper to
all the fun toys he had this next
bedroom is actually a playroom which is
totally fitting considering the
inspiration for this it's Toy Story this
amazing playroom is part of a Disney
cruise ship we have never wanted
anything more than to set sail and hang
out in Andy's room look at these amazing
colors the entire room looks like it's
made up of giant toys so if you've ever
wondered what it's like to be one of
buzz and Woody's pals this is your
chance
slinky serves as the slide and they even
have the cloud wallpaper in the
background you can see ham and mr.
Potato Head Andy's bed serves as an
upper level playing area we wonder if
Buzz is waiting to show us how he can
fly The Lion King The Lion King is a
movie blasting with gorgeous color and
memorable characters Simba's adventure
as a young cub and later as an adult
lion made us want to visit the pride
lands and the jungle much like Simba's
transition into adulthood
we have to grow up too but as adults how
do we incorporate our love of Disney
without seeming too childish
we definitely
want to let go of our favorite films
especially this one we can try
decorating our rooms like this
sophisticated individual did they
created an elegant Sahara landscape
inspired by Simba's home they kept the
color palette monochromatic focusing on
warm tones like deep oranges yellow
brown and tans the furniture is simple
and classy the bedding is animal print
which is a fun way to include the
animals from the film the room is
completed with a Simba plush and there
is mosquito netting on the windows and
curtains that look like canvas tents the
nightstands even resemble travel
suitcases and the lats are camping
lanterns how amazing and classy is this
room Peter Pan speaking of flying let's
talk about our favorite flyer Peter Pan
the eternal youth who teaches us to
believe in magic and fairies also taught
us how to fly all you need is a little
faith trust and pixie dust and you're
ready to soar we would love to visit
Neverland and hang out with Tinker Bell
and Peter but they haven't shown up in
our room yet so we have to settle for
bringing the magic to our rooms that's
exactly what this creative person did
here we have a Peter Pan inspired
bedroom with an elegant twist although
Peter Pan is about never growing up this
bedroom is classy and sophisticated we
love the clean look and simplicity of
this room the clean lines and curves of
the furniture are very stylish the blue
and orange are a lively pop of color the
painting of Peter Wendy John Michael and
Tinkerbell flying over London and across
the big bin is amazingly detailed it's
not overwhelmingly themed but still
enough to inspire us just look at the
hot air balloon chandelier it's so
beautifully crafted this room is a great
example of how to do Disney for adults
what a great balance of modern classical
and Disney styles princesses we know
sometimes making choices is difficult
and when it comes to Disney movies there
is no exception there are so many great
stories we can't imagine having to
choose one so what do you do when you
want to decorate your room but can't
decide what to pick well why not choose
a little bit of everything if you love
all of the Disney Princesses
we suggest incorporating them in
your room just like some of these
creative people this person decided to
make one of their walls
a mural including various princesses we
love the patterns and bright colors in
each princess panel they kept the focus
on the princesses by making the
furniture and bedding white and free of
patterns a bold choice we also love this
other bedroom that used Ariel in
Cinderella their mural of the castle and
courtyard made us fill this bedroom is
part of a spectacular castle especially
with Ariel and Cinderella waiting
outside by the fountain the detail in
the brick includes hints of purple and
pink
this colorful masterpiece looks like it
could be a still frame from an actual
Disney movie we love the creativity
frozen frozen took the world by storm in
2013 lucky for us the cold never
bothered us anyway the film features
Princess Anna and her sister Queen Elsa
who accidentally freezes her kingdom
with her powers the lovely story of
sisterly love
combined with catchy songs and beautiful
animation is enough to solidify its
place in Disney history the design of
the film is mostly a beautiful winter
wonderland consisting of lots of blues
and purples naturally this inspired mini
frozen themed bedrooms some included
scenes of the landscape on their walls
as well as the characters such as Elsa
Anna and Olaf other bedroom was went
with a subtle approach and stuck to a
blue color and white color palette
sprinkling snowflake decor on the walls
we loved all of the different ways this
movie has inspired the decor of bedrooms
picking white furniture is a good way to
stay versatile while keeping the winter
theme the blues White's pinks and
purples are a fun way to play around
with accent colors around the room
weather subtle or full-blown we just
need our very own little Olaf and we are
ready to let it go Alice in Wonderland
there are many wonderful Disney films to
draw inspiration from if you are a big
fan of color texture and crazy patterns
then look no further than Alice in
Wonderland
this movie is filled with whimsical
inspiration
Barry Blair was the concept artist for
the film and she did amazing work here
is a bedroom inspired by the film and
just like Mary's work it's hard not to
be inspired this designer certainly took
Alice's adventurous spirit and went with
it there are so many patterns and colors
here from the flowers to the bold prints
on the bedding and the mushrooms even
the tree that Alice falls into is
incorporated into the bed and how cool
are these beanbag chairs made to look
like stones the flower pillows blend
perfectly with the flowers painted on
the wall if you look closely you can see
Alice the Hatter and the Cheshire Cat
hanging out by the flower bed this
beautiful forest really captures the fun
and brightness of Alice in Wonderland
let's just hope the Red Queen doesn't
show up and threatens to take our heads
Cinderella when we watch Disney
Cinderella all we really want is a fairy
godmother to make our dreams come true
Cinderella is the hopeful girl who
dreams of escaping her evil stepmothers
grasp after having her plans and dress
ruined by her stepmother and stepsisters
Cinderella is visited by her fairy
godmother and bibbidi-bobbidi-boo a
little magic and Cinderella is able to
go to the ball her glittering dress and
gorgeous glass slippers had us wishing
for our own transformation and if
Cinderella taught us one thing it's to
dream since a dream is a wish your heart
makes why not turn your sleeping area
into something magical if your room is
looking a little like Cinderella before
the magic why not take a little
inspiration from the princess herself
this gorgeous Cinderella inspired
bedroom is giving us major fields the
absolutely magical landscape of the
castle on the wall makes us feel like we
are in a fairy tale the beautiful
bedding is basically Cinderella's dress
and we are obsessed the attention to
detail in the bedding is exquisite from
the ruffles to the color and the
butterflies all that is missing are the
glass slippers and our own pumpkin
carriage pumpkin carriage speaking of
Cinderella's carriage how cool would it
be to have one of those I'm
imagine having a pumpkin transform into
a sweet ride in front of your eyes that
would be something to see
of course Cinderella's dress and shoes
were necessary for the princess
transformation but one of the coolest
changes that happened was the pumpkin
the elegant round carriage was the
finishing touch on Cinderella's princess
transformation we all wished we could
ride it everywhere but would you want to
sleep in it some creative designers took
the carriage and let it inspire them
this Cinderella carriage themed room is
enough to make us feel like we are being
whisked away to our castles the white
and gold carriage looks almost exactly
like the one in the movie we love the
pop of blue in the bedding and curtains
inside it reminds us of Cinderella's
dress there is even a wishing well and a
faux cobblestone path we are totally
loving the wide open fields painted on
the wall it's almost like looking out
into our own kingdom now all we need are
some horses and we're ready for
dreamland which of these gorgeous rooms
was your favorite let us know in the
comments section below if you'd like to
see more videos like this one then don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]